ja sehr herzlichen dank sind ja sonst
materiell im zeitpunkt der
rechtsfrieden herrschen man kann ich
ist erneut festgenommen worden ist in
einzelfallgerechtigkeit ist ein
entscheidungsfindung dem staatlichen
immer aufregerthemen die mitgebrachten
laufenden verjährung mord verjährt nie
dann wieder anfangen alles wieder von
anspruch ist genüge getan ich meine sie
interesse aber es ist nicht das
untersuchungshaft gesteckt worden ist
vorne auf eine hochinteressante rechts
aber es ist bereits ein prozess
ich habe eine schöne entscheidung eines
vordringliche interesse in einem
reißen da eine ganz ganz gefährliche
das hat das oberlandesgericht celle
philosophische frage ich könnte
innerhalb der verjährung begonnen worden
oberlandesgerichtes mitgebracht was die
linie 1 und wenn man damit anfängt dann
gestern bestätigt hat gesagt ja die
strafprozess der schon einmal
stundenlang zuhören sind sie beides
durchgeführt wurde und dass herr luca
und es ist auch dieser staatliche
wirklich rechtsgeschichte schreiben
anwälte oder warum also dann leben wir
untersuchungshaft ist rechtmäßig das
wirklich gerne vorstellen möchte er
ist eben die frage wo hört man dann auf
strafanspruch geprüft worden und bis zu
ist ein ganz ganz elementarer grundsatz
ganze gesetz ist auch verfassungsgemäß
sie sagen jetzt heute sollen die delikte
uns doch zurück und machen sogar richter
unterricht der auffassung liegt die
also eine wirklich gute entscheidung so
ende geprüft worden das heißt es ist
möchte eine kleine geschichte zu
seien die nie verjähren okay vielleicht
union völlig falsch aus gründen der
hold für das interessante ist wenn jeder
erzählen im jahr 1981 das ein ganz
keine verjährungsfrist das verfahren ist
und jetzt kommt aber dann doch der
einzelfallgerechtigkeit den rechtsstaat
ist es morgen ein anderes delikt
aufreger die ampel der ist der
irgendwie jeder von ihnen spricht bin
zu schleifen und damit sollten wir nicht
durch und selbst wenn ich an die liegt
interessanter kriminalfall der auf ihren
vielleicht ist es morgen auch der
ich immer der meinung von dem der
anfangen ich möchte ganz vehement
justizminister von der fdp und auch die
spricht gerade weil sich beide so
steuersünder oder was eben gefallen ist
habe was nicht verkehrt wenn der staat
widersprechen sie habe zu recht darauf
bekanntesten 1981 wurde die damals 17
plausibel argumentieren
grünen die wollen jetzt möglicherweise
zum schluss kommt ich kann nicht
da muss man aufpassen das sind
hingewiesen dass wir rechtsfrieden
jährige schülerin friederike von müller
beweisen dass eine schuld vorlag und
dieses gesetz wieder abschaffen die wahl
grundsätze wenn wir sie einreichen wenn
brauchen rechtsfrieden ist ein ausfluss
wir damit anfangen eine mauer
man erst entführt dann wurde sie
sagen nämlich das war ja alles an einem
der rechtsstaatlichkeit und das ist ein
deswegen gibt es einen freispruch dann
so ist es also fynn holpert viertel nach
einzureißen in dem moment kann es sein
freispruch unter vorbehalt das können
vergewaltigt und schließlich ermordet
ganz hohes gut da bin ich ganz bei ihnen
ist recht gesprochen dann ist dem
dass sie für immer in sich
acht immer mehr zum tausch der
allerdings frage ich was kann denn ein
wir so nicht hinnehmen und ich glaube
strafanspruch innerhalb der verjährung
gebildeten stände das begrüße ich sehr
man hat dann einen mann als ihren
das wäre wirklich ein affront wenn man
genügt worden und die verjährung läuft
mutmaßlichen täter festgenommen martin
demenz gibt es dann vielleicht noch
so etwas machen würde einer frau
falscher freispruch an rechtsfrieden
höhere kätzchen darstellen
dann nicht weiter weil das verfahren
gegenüber den parlamentarischen
angeklagt er ist auch verurteilt worden
gesetzgeber der letzten wahlperiode aber
rechtskräftig abgeschlossen ist und
tatsächlich bringen wenn hinterher klar
selbstverständlich muss das jetzt
diese rechtskraft beseitigt ein
wegen vergewaltigung wegen mordes er hat
vor allen dingen ein affront gegenüber
ist das ist ein mörder wir können es mit
auflösen
nochmaliger möglichkeit der staat nicht
allerhöchster wahrscheinlichkeit
den angehörigen von mordopfern
dann berufung gegen dieses urteil
ich würde als jemand der nicht jura
nachweisen und das sind ja die
nach einjähriger freispruch hat
eingelegt das ist dann bis zum
die ampel hat sich selber in ihrem
voraussetzung ist ja nicht so dass man
studiert hat dennoch ein doktortitel
natürlich ein geschmäckle also wenn er
bundesgerichtshof hochgegangen der
koalitionsvertrag als ein bündnis für
jedes verfahren wieder öffnen kann
bis zum falschparken oder ein
bundesgerichtshof hatte das urteil
hatte er sich nicht erschlichen hat ich
sondern die hürden sind hoch es geht um
steuerdelikt geht will ich voll auf
gerechtigkeit bezeichnet und ich finde
aufgehoben und am ende hat dieser mann
ihrer seite aber wenn wir wissen das ist
exzeptionelle es unrecht um mord und
sage das primäre empfinden dass ich habe
wenn man gerechtigkeit ob wolken lassen
ein mörder und sagen leider aus rechts
den gerichtssaal als freier mann
ist das teilen vielleicht doch mehr
völkermord also verbrechen gegen die
kann dann muss dieses gesetz bestehen
verlassen weil er aus mangel an beweisen
leute als hier am tisch sitzen wenn
technischen gründen muss der frei
freigesprochen worden das war im jahre
bleiben das sind wir den angehörigen
menschlichkeit alles das was in unserer
herumlaufen und muss ich sagen habe habe
jemand einen mord begangen hat dann soll
schuldig und das ist das was mich
rechtsordnung als unverlierbare
1983 fast 30 jahre später gab es dann
ich auch ein problem und ich finde diese
persönlich gestern wahnsinnig bewegt hat
er dafür zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
straftaten gewertet werden also wo ist
differenzierung ist auch wichtig es geht
das würde ich erst mal sagen und wenn er
das unrecht wirklich mit händen zu
hallo die ampel hat das ja nicht ganz
eben nicht um das knöllchen das geht
jetzt halt irgendwie glück hat sich da
aufgrund der fortentwicklung der
greifen ist nur in diesen
nicht um die einfache fahrlässige
irgendwie durchgemogelt zu haben oder
ohne grund getan sondern es gibt einen
kriminaltechnik eine dna-analyse die mit
konstellationen sohnes gelten und ich
körperverletzung oder es geht wirklich
denn der zeuge in dem moment als er
finde auch die die materielle
ganz ganz wichtigen grundsatz in unserem
um die konstellation wo unsere
aufgefunden werden sollte ich auch
rechtsstaat denn der rechtsstaat muss ja
einer sehr hohen wahrscheinlichkeit
gerechtigkeit das ist auch
gefunden werden sollte oder vielleicht
rechtsordnung ganz elementar sagt das
festgestellt hat dass dieser mann der
kernbestandteil unserer
technische möglichkeiten es später
nicht nur gewährleisten dass es
rechtsstaatlichkeit und ich glaube wir
kommen sie haben das erwähnte
wiegt so schwer dieses unrecht das ist
täter war weil man samen spuren bei der
einzelfallgerechtigkeit gibt sondern er
dna-analyse gab sehr wenig wissen wir
weil sie gerade sagt wir dürfen den
vergewaltigung ihm zuweisen konnte und
noch nicht einmal verliert das kann man
muss eben auch dafür sorgen dass es
alle wie columbo angucken die feuerwehr
rechtsstaat nicht schreiben ich glaube
in 50 jahren immer noch anklagen wenn
wir schleifen den rechtsstaat im
rechts frieden gibt und so tragisch dass
hat allen 18 minuten gelöst mit dna gab
jetzt würde man ja normalerweise denken
gegenteil dann wenn wir es zulassen dass
man dann die entsprechenden beweise hat
der muss doch jetzt wieder angeklagt
es damals nicht mehr viel aufwendiger
und einer konstellation wo es auf der
auch im einzelfall sein kann gibt es
also ich würde einfach sagen wenn ihr
werden wir mussten ihm muss der prozess
es solche falschen freisprüche gibt wo
gemacht werden er muss hinter schloss
mann ein mord begangen hat ich habe
hand liegt dass jemand der täter ist nur
eben einen ganz elementaren grundsatz in
und riegel das lässt aber unsere
jetzt auch noch den kopf mord verjährt
evident ist dass sie falsch sind das
um die konzentration geht es ja wo es
unserem strafrecht und das ist der
nicht dann soll er vom rechtsstaat zur
strafprozessordnung nicht zu und das ist
völlig klar ist aufgrund einer neuen
mindert die akzeptanz in den rechtsstaat
grundsatz der die römer schon kennen aus
verantwortung für diese böse tat gezogen
beweislage das ist der täter dann zu
dem grundsatz des nebels in den sie auch
und das ist am ende ein viel größerer
etwas was ich als unerträglichen zustand
werden und wenn das erst 30 jahre später
sagen als rechtsordnung auch als
empfunden habe was glaube ich auch dem
schaden als wenn man jetzt in einem in
angesprochen hatten man solle nicht
ist aber dennoch eine gerechte strafe
gesellschaft den lassen wir aber in
zweimal in derselben sache nicht nur
rechtsempfinden der allermeisten
ist würde ich sagen diese 20 jahren frei
einer besonderen situation in einem
freiheit weiterlaufen das widerspricht
menschen in unserem land widerspricht
verurteilt werden sondern es soll auch
dazwischen hat er nicht verdient und ich
einzelfall aber in einer besonderen
meinem rechtsempfinden zutiefst und ist
situation die klar geregelt ist mit
in zwei mal kein prozess gegen
und deswegen haben wir als cdu csu
weiß nicht was tut ein doktor gemacht du
auch etwas was den rechtsfrieden eben
fraktion in der letzten wahlperiode ein
klaren und strikten würden hier eine
eingeführt werden wenn ein rechtsstaat
gerade nicht herstellt das ist am ende
hast mich die situation
solche wiederaufnahme des verfahrens
einmal ein verfahren gegen einen bürger
gesetz durchgesetzt auf den weg gebracht
eben auch die abwägung sie über zu
zulässt nein da muss da muss die
treffen haben rechtssicherheit auf der
also das ist sozusagen die die
was genau diesen missstand ab stehen
geführt hat und es dem rechtsstaat nicht
einen seite da bin ich ganz bei ihnen
staatsanwaltschaft wenn eben zweifel
die es ist ein hohes gut aber die
gelungen ist den strafanspruch des
sollte was möglichkeiten schaffen sollte
rechtsfrieden oder uns ist hergestellt
bestehen ob man das ganze durchsetzen
materielle gerechtigkeit das ist doch
staates zu beweisen und der bürger ist
kann auf der basis der rechtslage dann
diese verfahren wieder neu aufzurollen
und also bist du jetzt doch wieder auch
das streben eines strafprozesses
auch genau abwägen ob man auf dieser
er bei akt das wort ich glaube bei
also frei gesprochen worden dann ist es
materielle gerechtigkeit herzustellen zu
gegen erhebliche widerstände die spd
beweislage schon das verfahren führen
unverjährbar straftaten muss muss muss
ein ganz ganz elementarer grundsatz dass
justizministerin christine lambrecht das
sühnen und wenn das nicht
will und ob man das verfahren zu ende
man dann sagt damit ist wenn auch hier
führen will wenn die staatsanwaltschaft
aufs schärfste bekämpft auch die fdp im
vollzogen werden kann weil es sozusagen
man da wahrscheinlich muss man da
sich entscheidet und wenn das gericht
das ganze in der dritten instanz schon
bundestag und die grünen haben dagegen
wahrscheinlich
das ganze zur verhandlung zulässt und
bis zum bgh gegangen ist in die revision
muss man wahrscheinlich den
einen fall einen freispruch falsch ist
gestimmt die wollten dass alle nicht
dann wird diese verhandlung durchgeführt
weil sie gesagt haben das ist alles
der aber hinterher als falsch erweist
rechtsfrieden
dann muss auch irgendwann rechtsfrieden
dann muss auch irgendwann wenn dann
verfassungswidrig in unserer grundgesetz
dann muss man auch die möglichkeit haben
hinstellen würden sich wahrscheinlich in
dieses verfahren zugunsten der person
herrscht man muss auch irgendwann
in der rechtsordnung das zu korrigieren
ist es verboten jemanden zweimal zu
schluss sein und dann kann der
momentan ich will dem dringend
und das haben wir jetzt gemacht und
die betroffen ist ausgeht dann muss auch
rechtsstaat nicht kommen und sagen dass
bestrafen was auch stimmt aber wie
deswegen muss das auch bestehen bleiben
irgendwann schluss sein und dann kann
er dann nach einigen jahrzehnten sich
der freispruch ist nach der materiellen
entgegentreten denn was ist verjährung
gesagt natürlich muss es möglich sein in
man nicht kommen und dann noch mal sagen
nochmal die sache anschaut dann nochmal
rechtslage in dem zeitpunkt wo hergang
verjährung bedeutet das wenn ein prozess
diesen
okay jetzt nehme ich die noch mal ran da
neue beweismittel mit einbringt das geht
fällen wo es um exzeptionelle unrecht
ist richtig gewesen da ist gar keine
muss der rechtsstaat auch irgendwann da
gibt so etwas zu machen und das haben
nur in ganz engen grenzen und diese ganz
nicht rechtzeitig angestrengt wird das
ist das strafverfahren durchlaufen dann
frage da passt auch die maus keinen
wir am ende durchsetzen können und jetzt
engen grenzen hat die union hier
dann irgendwann keine verfolgung mehr
hat diese person ein jahrelanger prozess
hat das oberlandesgericht celle weil
verlassen in der letzten
faden ab das ist so und da muss man
stattfinden kann wir sprechen hier aber
legislaturperiode aus den gründen der
durchlaufen und wenn das dann geschehen
über einen frei wo im laufe der
dieser mann aufgrund dieses neuen
einfach sagen prozessual und auch
einzelfall sicherheit und das ist
gesetzes was erst wenige wochen in kraft
ist muss auch irgendwann der